sur france info on a appris que le
premier pub entièrement sans alcool mais
d'ouvrir ses portes il m'a dublin
d'ouverture et tireuses à bière
rien ne différencie le veer d'une main
vis des autres marques du blanc pourtant
ici ce n'est pas de la guinness qui
coule à flots mais bien des boissons
sans alcool
une première en irlande se pare d'un
nouveau genre a ouvert début mai et
s'est rapidement fait un nom à dublin
une performance dans cette ville où les
peuples sont des institutions la carte
des boissons a été élaboré en
s'inspirant de celle des 750 pop
traditionnel de la capitale irlandaise
face à cette concurrence les clients du
virgin mary peuvent au moins se vanter
de pouvoir faire la fête sans risquer la
gueule de bois
alors je vais me tourner vers la
princesse à terre et de nier de l'accord
matin c'est comment ces savez quand vous
savez que dans le pays
il ya quand même le reste du pays c'est
avec des pubs avait quelque chose à
laquelle je ne plaisante pas c'est comme
une partie de jambes en l'air son
orgasme
ça peut-être faisant ses propres ailes
ces jeunes qui veulent faire des steak
de soja sexe et de l'avion saillon
pression mais c'est surtout que
imaginons voir une buvait jamais
d'alcool non j'aime mais n'a pas pu pour
mon goût imaginons on veut sortir tout
et deux oui et bien j'irai jamais avec
vous c'est quoi bref ça sent son pardon
et passer une soirée sans boire d'alcool
quand même je rappelle que sans alcool
la fête est plus folle
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas les très bons scores que fait
ce café sécurité toute la série exemple
par exemple même pas une petite coupette
de champagne jacquart du champomy à
morel petits modèles avec une petit
nombre l2 dans un mélange de jeu c'est
pas d' orange citron chez de la voir tél
il y à de l'alcool dedans sinon ce n'est
pas un cocktail et bar tabac le nom de
qui se moque t'on l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la consommer avec
modération
le deviner ce que vous partagez la vie
de votre camarade qui visiblement et
j'avoue il est alors à mon corps
défendant
évidemment je partage je suis plus team
cocktail comme octets le mot peut-être
rien plongeon ça moche pardon ma pitel
c'est moche maintenant maintenant je
trouve ça génial pour l'irlande de
surfer vous savez sur les filets le fils
elle fit vibe du moment là c'est bien m
exactement c'est geignard dont mais
c'est bien aussi qu'ils aient une offre
pour déposer plus jeune de ses deux ans
dans un pub et aux bulles se sentir
entre guillemets obligé pour faire comme
les copains vierge se prendre de
l'alcool n'est pas bien ça existe ça
c'est pas une nouvelle initiative ça
existe déjà ça s'appelle la salle de
réunion
[Applaudissements]
il ya d'autres vidéos étaient déjà là
c'est assez sectaire quand même on
n'intervient pas pardon mais moi
pardonnez moi mais lorsque je sors
investi je sors avec vous évidemment
vous devez vous pouvez tout c'est que
moi je ne bois pas du coup je me sens
prise à défaut vous retrouvez à passer
toutes vos soirées et damien kani bé oui
d'amira tous les deux parce que je
trouve ce concept et faire part parce
que le problème aujourd'hui c'est que
dès lors qu'on est majeur et qu'on a
trois poils au menton se sent obligé de
boire de l'alcool sous peine de passer
pour un ringard donc moi personnellement
j'en ai marre de passer pour le pré
pubères de service qui boit un thé glacé
mathématiquement tuller du coup je suis
content qu'il y ait ce genre de
d'établissement pour enfin man canayer
avec un soda sans qu'il n'y ait le
regard pressant des ménages ressemble à
la vous m'aidez pas l'ignorer mais pas
la cause doit écouter le premier peuple
sans alcool qui vient doubler d'ouvrir à
dublin est ce que c'est une bonne idée
mais bien senna problèmes ont une bonne
idée meurtre universel et 5e première
voilà
vous viendrez pas à la c'est une fille
hila et évidemment on dit souvent que
sans alcool donc une dizaine la fête est
plus folle bien sûr
[Musique]
voilà qui part donc avec un beau
cocktail qu'on ferait ça la connerie là
c'est pas l'alcool est pas faux